hubo acuerdo entre los líderes de la
Unión Europea en Bruselas para prohibir
parcialmente la exportación del petróleo
ruso al bloque de 27 naciones esto cubre
inmediatamente más de dos tercios de las
importaciones de petróleo de Rusia
cortando una enorme fuente de
financiamiento para su maquinaria de
guerra la jefa De la comisión europea
Úrsula fonder Legends destacó que para
final de año la prohibición debería
alcanzar el 90%. los líderes también
acordaron aislar al mayor banco ruso es
verbank del sistema Swift y prohibir
otras tres emisoras estatales rusas
llegar al castigo energético No fue
fácil las discusiones del día estuvieron
marcadas por un clima tenso dada la
oposición inicial del húngaro Víctor
osvald su país depende en un 65% del
petróleo Ruso y no tiene una alternativa
inmediata tampoco tiene salida al océano
por ello finalmente El veto solo
incluirá el transporte de crudo por mar
y no por oleoducto excepción que también
consiguió el voto favorable de
Eslovaquia y república más temprano
celenski presionó a los líderes reunidos
en la Cumbre denunciando un trato blando
hacia Moscú
debemos poner fin a todas las rencillas
en Europa rencillas internas que solo
animan a Rusia a ejercer más y más
presión sobre ustedes sobre toda Europa
mientras alertó que la situación era muy
delicada en el dumbase
febrero febrero
y algunos otros asentamientos siguen
siendo los objetivos clave para los
ocupantes
tenéis que crítico también el bloqueo de
grano ucraniano por parte de Rusia desde
el comienzo de la invasión de Ucrania
Rusia ya ha recibido más de 20.000
millones de euros procedentes de la
compra de petróleo de la Unión Europea